what's your opinion
on my bird here Mr parrot it's a maau
Scarlet MAA what it is a Scarlet maau oh
you know Birds yeah and that's actually
not life-sized are you saying he's not
real I'm saying it's not to scale okay
but he's real are we doing that Monty
Python
sketch everything is a Monty Python sket
I don't think I thought's funny and at
all like not that explains so much does
it what does it explain what do you
think is
funny you're not answering that question
is pretty funny yeah what what do you
think is funny having a met a shrimp no
that you think big Leos is funny oh God
no although this is getting worse and
worse to be fair yep I only tried to
watch big Labowski after it's been part
of the culture for many years right to
the point where every single line has
been quoted incessantly by the most
annoying frat Bros ever yeah so I kind
of have been poisoned to be able to
appreciate it right so maybe if I'd seen
it when it came out before it became a
thing I would have enjoyed it I couldn't
get through it like I couldn't get
through 20 minutes is that how you feel
about Schindler's
List well it's so much easier for me to
stare at you when you have S glasses on
I didn't think you'd be the one making
Holocaust jokes today and yet here we
are and cut scene I actually have like
no trouble making eye contact with you
when you're wearing Shades yes cuz
you're a robot two two copies of myself
yeah oh you seeing yourself in them mhm
okay cool yeah I'm having a conversation
with myself it's not your fault
Lex they made you like this you were
just a good little robot in St
Petersburg I could see Mr parrot a
little bit too well what do you find
funny come on let's this is an
interesting subject well I find Mighty
python I find AB absurdity funny yes I
find absurdity funny I I think that's
the thing when people come at me and
maybe this is an Eastern European thing
yeah when they're like how can you find
this like very dark Subject funny it's
like well the humor first of all the
humor is that
you're making fun of something that's
dark so already it's absurd like it's
completely inappropriate second just
psychologically you know Joan Rivers
said that Winston shers said I don't
know if it's true that when you make
people laugh you're giving them a little
vacation mhm and I was just thinking
about this the other day how when I die
if I want my funeral to be a roast yeah
it doesn't help me that everyone's sad
if I brought people happiness or joy in
life whatever I want to keep doing that
in death you're sadness doesn't help me
I know you can't help it but tell
stories how I made you laugh make fun of
me make me the punching bag even
literally take me out of that coffin and
beat the I don't make me Piñata I don't
care so I I think and it it's it's I
don't understand well I do understand
but it's sad for me when people are like
you know this isn't funny that isn't
funny I the way I look at humor is the
way it's like a chef right it's pretty
easy to make bacon taste good but some
of these really obscure ingredients to
make it palatable that's takes skill so
if you're dealing with a subject that is
very emotional or intense and you can
make people
laugh then that takes skill and that's
the relief for them
yeah it's all about timing yeah
yeah what's the different you want to
hear one of my jokes uh is it a pirate
joke because that's the only that's the
only kind I accept today but now go
ahead it doesn't have to be a pirate
joke this one time do you know who Leah
Thomas is yeah what's the difference
between Leah Thomas and Hitler what Leah
Thomas knows how to finish a
race very nice very nice uh I just get
the gold medal good job uh why does it
take uh Pirates forever to get through
the
alphabet why because they spent years at
C Oh I thought it was GNA be R joke
that's a good one I like that when I was
in North Korea one oh you know Dennis
robman it's a callback by the way the
thing that is very heartbreaking about
the North Korean situation is that they
have a great sense of humor
uh it would be a lot easier if these
were like robots or drones they have big
personalities big senses of humor and
that made it much harder to leave and
interact with these people because it
it's I mean there's nothing more human
in Universal than than laughter and
laughter's free are you saying there's
humor even amongst the people that have
most of their freedoms taken away
especially I mean again we're from you
know the Soviet Union like there's a
anot there's a I mean Russian humor is a
thing because it's there nothing you can
this if you can't have food or nice
things at least you can have joy and
make each other laugh I think about it
all the time and I think about my guide
all the time it's been what uh 2012 so
it's been 11 years since I've been there
and she's still there and everyone I've
seen is still there they just recently
um electrified the Border uh so you
can't even even the few people who are
escaping can't do it
anymore but that's interesting that they
still have a sense of humor I tribute to
the Soviet Union for having that because
of the uh like really deep education
system like you you got to read a lot of
literature
okay and because of that you get to kind
of learn about the the cruelty the
injustices the absurdity of the world as
long as the writing is not about the
current regime yeah but I think like if
you look at like African-Americans
Jewish Americans gay Americans they are
all disproportionate in terms of
attributing to Comedy it's not because
these groups some have some kind of you
know magic to them it's that when you
are on the outside looking in a you're
going to have different perspective
effective than the people who are in the
middle of the bell curve but also when
you don't have anything to lose at the
very least you can make each other laugh
and and find happiness that way um so
you know that is something that I think
um is an important thing to
recognize